Hey everybody,
welcome back to this lesson on style.
Before we start,
I want to introduce you to James Parks,
another course developer
here at Udacity.
>> Hi there.
>> By now you've learned how to
develop your first website with HTML.
Now James is here to help you
take things a little further and
add some style to your sites.
>> Right, in this lesson, you'll be
writing CSS to improve the look of your
sites, and along the way you'll
try out browser developer tools.
Dev tools are incredibly
useful amongst other things
you'll find that you can test styles
really, really quickly using them.
>> That's awesome, I love DEV tools.
All right, that's it for me now i'm
going to leave you to it james.
>> All right, let's get started.